[Musique]
tu te souviens vraiment de rien je me
souviens de rien je me souviens juste
de l'interprète
[Musique]
pourquoi vous voulez ce travail ça gagne
bien chef
ne nous déçoit pas on ne veut pas la
casse-couille non pas moi chef il veut
pas ce boulot que pour l'argent
les talibans ont tué son fils
s'il vous plaît c'est trop de faut
surtout pas la prendre tu dépasses
limite tu es ici pour traduire mon rôle
en fait c'est interpréter
les enfants et moi on a cru que tu avais
été tué on doit cet homme de t'avoir
sauvé la vie comme si celui suffisait
pas de m'avoir porter dans la montagne
maintenant il se cache dans un trou
quelque part en fait c'est moi qui dois
être dans le truc
est-ce que tout va bien non tout ne va
pas bien il y a une déchirure en moi
Ahmed et sa famille sont pris au piège
on ne peut pas intervenir
je vais te voir les exfiltrer moi-même
écoute tu te retrouveras seul
tu sais qu'il faut s'adapter
et avec ce que tu as
il faut que tu me dises où il se cache
et je le ferai sortir de cette ancêtres
et trop dangereux
tu es devenu très populaire chez les
talibans
tu me manques au revoir au revoir
er de cette tête je le ferai pas
mais vous croyez que j'ai le choix
d'autre choix
[Musique]